20 years before the Apple watch as we
know it today there was this the very
first Apple watch in May of 1995 Apple
released Macintosh system 7.5 and to
encourage people to buy it they offered
a free gift you could either choose a
copy of conflict catcher 3 or you could
get an Apple watch this is not the
original strap it came with the original
strap but after like two or three days
of wearing it that strap broke down it
was just too old so this is a strap from
one of my grandfather's old watches the
design on the watch is phenomenal it's
reminiscent of Silverstein the Memphis
group I love it take a look at that
second hand it's like a little
shape that many have pointed out might
have foreshadowed the hockey puck Mouse